[Music]
yo what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is google home mini it's 49 bucks and
that's almost all that matters here we
already had the original google home
which i think right now is 129
but this little one is a game changer
because it does
all of the exact same stuff the big one
does
but for less than half the price and in
a way smaller package so here's
everything you need to know if you're
considering getting a google home mini
first of all i review the original
google home i have a couple of them now
in the studio and at home it looks like
this pretty solid google home mini looks
like this it comes in three different
colors the coral chalk and charcoal and
i know the size on the scale is
sometimes hard to show so there you go
right around four inches across it's
like the size of a donut and when you
plug it in it basically looks like this
fabric pebble with lights i feel like it
could kind of blend into almost any room
in most houses pretty easily especially
in this gray color
volume up volume down and long press to
actually physically trigger the
assistant otherwise you can do it with
your voice of course because there are
microphones and then you pair it up with
the google home app on your iphone or
android phone and you're good to go
again everything is the same here as the
bigger google home the only physical
disadvantage of being smaller
is the smaller speaker here obviously
the single upward firing speaker can't
give you quite the same volume as the
three speaker setup of the google home
which is kind of a big deal for some
people maybe those who listen to music a
lot but for most this single speaker is
really just fine
[Music]
google actually calls it a 360 degree
sound but that's just their way of
making a single upward firing driver
sound cool uh but it's just basically
it's unidirectional there's no other
direction one big speaker could face i
just do think it would benefit from
having an audio jack for people who
actually just want to plug it into some
speakers and benefit from better sound
and while we're on it i do have some
other minor complaints about the
hardware number one i wish it was usb-c
they went with micro usb even though
it's 2017 and this thing only has one
port it could have easily been usb-c
come on google but then the bigger
complaint is the mute switch it's
actually kind of annoying you can
already mute google home by asking it to
but in the case that you actually want a
physical button the regular google home
has a button on the back to quickly mute
it you just press it again to unmute it
but if you mute google home mini with
your voice then when you go to unmute it
with the switch you got to flip it once
and then flip it back because it was
already flipped to unmuted when you
started it's like those rooms with two
light switches like ones up and one's
down but you want to turn the lights on
with one to turn it down and then it
turn it up and it just it's out of sync
after a while bottom line is it should
have been a button not a switch would
have been much easier but from there
everything else about this 49 google
home mini is exactly the same as the 129
dollar regular sized google home so all
the same commands the same phone call
ability the same ai all that useful
stuff hey google find my phone
i found a few phones the first listed is
a sum in nine five oh you want
should i read it yes
all right your phone should be raining
now
hey google
how long have there been sharks on earth
420 million years
on the website sharksavers.org they say
hey google what is the surface
temperature of the sun
the surface temperature of sun is
5778 kelvin hey google
show me essential phone videos
sure playing essential phone videos from
youtube on studio
is it going to rain today yes the
forecast for today in kearney is 77
degrees fahrenheit with rain hey google
what's the tallest building in europe
tallest buildings in europe include oco
tower at 1 160 feet hey google play a b
flat sure here's a b flat
[Music]
hey google roll a 12 sided die
coming right up
it's a three hey google how many pints
are in a quart
one u.s liquid port equals two u.s
liquid pints
that's pretty easy so this fits nicely
in a sort of a lineup now they have the
google home mini and the regular one and
the macs at like three way different
price points and it's still gaining
features as time goes on so like there's
stuff that hasn't been fully activated
yet i can't do texting yet on my google
homes but that's something that'll be
available soon so that's basically it
it's a mini review for a mini speaker
again it's all stuff we've seen before
but the main new thing really here is
just the price being 49 bucks brings it
down into competition with all the
people considering buying amazon echo
dot that's also about 45 bucks right now
so let me know if that new price point
is enough to possibly convince you in
the comments below i'll hang out down
there that's pretty much it thank you
for watching talk to you guys the next
one
peace
[Music]
you